we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two david p let's take a listen
to this voicemail i know you're super
high taking on david but which guy
realized you know there's nothing else
but it's a vision of ways for people to
get information about chair to sell to
somebody else make money off it it has
enough value clear american people and
people that live their lives when
internet like i'm for you you crazy
what do you think you can write but
they're not in copy okay why would you
want to give that to people yeah i think
the art but a deliberate delivery i
think the argument is we shouldn't be
concerned about net neutrality because
the internet is only good for people to
find information out about you and if
you live your life on the internet then
you're crazy it's not exactly an
argument against net neutrality that
i've heard before that it's just that
the internet's bad that's not I'm not
even sure I know how to respond to it I
mean in terms of people on the internet
being crazy I think we have someone here
who could be throwing stones from a
glass house yeah right yeah there's by
the way there's crazy people on the
internet and off the internet I don't
know that net neutrality really plays in
or factors into the sort of mental
status or health or balance of the
individuals on the internet there's
crazy people on both sides sure yes we
could say that we could indeed say that
on the bonus show today great bonus show
Israel and Poland are agreeing to talks
over a controversial Holocaust blame
bill parents are making their children
drink bleach to cure them of autism I
wonder if it's the autism that they
believe a vaccine caused to begin with
and a fitness tracking app has given
away the location of some secret US Army
bases around the world it's weird the
weird story get access to the bonus show
one of two ways become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership become a
patron at at least the $5 a month level
at patreon.com slash david pakman show